hey guys it's dense the founder frank
iero and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book in video game guru and this
is our review of true detective episode
7 after you've gone which is the second
to last episode the pen ultimate yet as
some would call it yeah I love this
episode I thought it was great
especially because you know did this
series is very dense there's a lot of a
lot of information going on a lot of
character names victim names ace names
locations all that stuff and in this
episode we finally are starting to put
the pieces together about who's you know
cuz sometimes you get a little lost your
like that who's doing what and in this
Pete this one kind of starts to put the
puzzle a little together you see the
total total family their lineage and my
family's been here for a long time you
know so I mean you see all the pieces
coming to it from the man with the scars
it was little hillbilly got you know
Forrest Gump Mona's grass out there too
I don't know his Billy Joe Dean and bit
you know Billy Bob you know Tuttle whose
ones not the governor but like one's a
senator senator when I big time the
Reverend like a lot of mother that huge
mansion that he you know broke in 20
which was I guess we did have a little
flashback this this we gotta see Matthew
McConaughey break into the guys house
you know as he's talking to rob sorry
not not cold but heart talking to heart
and let started let's talk about the his
little garage those little storage shed
little stories those stories you find
out what he's been doing for the last
two years I had assumed that he had been
doing it for further right we go to
Alaska or something to some last 10
years yeah we're gonna last go for a
while and first sir he came back and we
learned you know that heart I mean we
are a new heart was off the police r us
we don't how to find out why which is
really gross sickening bad story and
maybe in the right way I'm sure that
stuff is true you know yeah it's yeah I
don't know she bad as I said yeah but uh
well speaking of the the tunnels the man
with
scar right we saw him in episode I think
three ok and he was in front of the that
one school that they were early because
all the grass yeah he's clean mows the
lawn yeah it cuts a good and we didn't
notice his scars cuz I actually looked
back on the episode and can't see his
scars you you can't because he's got a
like a beard going oh and it's the
conversation with a Matthew
McConaughey's character rust at that
time it was very short he'd come there
this is before he went inside and looked
right he they got there he started to
ask a few questions and like you kind of
see him he also he's like from the side
alright and so you don't really see that
and then he gets called away really
quickly because that's when they found
out about LeDoux even at the end I
didn't know that was a man with scars
now this episode of the reason why is
because I was watching it I was laying
in bed and watching it on my my kindle
and it's clear but i don't think the
definite high definition was quite as
clear as it's on my TV so I'd like
rewind and kind of hold it up at all our
scars there you know yeah there are some
scars it's not quite as pronounced it
he's not like a spaghetti man but for my
little kids playing a little girl's
point of view he's gonna be a spaghetti
man it's gonna be scary yes so yeah with
that I love that ending I love the song
that they played at the end I looked it
up it was a towns Vance and yeah the
song's called lungs i love i love that
and I man and so now we know who this
man with the scars is and he obviously
plays a big role he's not the the yellow
King right but he's he's somebody that
that's around this this kind of ritual
ritualistic cult can't right yeah he's
he's a part of it and it starts at the
very top with his family the senator you
know rich big house all that kind of
stuff what I really liked is how the
show does is it's it's HBO it's dark and
have the nudity end the violence but
it's not as glorious that what a thought
it was going to be it's not Hannibal
which is super super bloody this is like
for instance there was this very dark
scene you know watch me nor watching
heart watch that little girl I don't
know what they did with their who can
only in bed it's all imagination which
is even almost worse I think that's one
actually seen it so effective and
there's over the baby like there's not
they don't show the gore of course are
not going to show a scene with little
girl
that what I mean that that imagination
our heads like they play with that and
it's it's scary and it's a really good
job no gore just this was the creepiest
episode for me oh yeah just because you
know with the whole baby thing yeah you
know they didn't show that but you know
they hint at it and and with that seen
the videotape in the storage locker and
then even when they go investigate in
and question the ex mate yeah yeah and
just like talking about car that was not
the end yeah like all that raises he
just really creepy stall right and like
so she knows some yeah and the girls
like oh she's going crazy no one makes
any sense and you know what heroes like
made perfect sense to me I mean she's
losing it that's it's really good I'm
glad we were I think we knew this I'm
glad that we've now confirmed that
Matthew McConaughey's character rust is
not he did not kill yeah you know these
people this is a bigger which is what i
want i'm glad that rust and heart unless
they flip a 180 in this finale like
because that's not what the shut this
show isn't about like you know secret
twist like I think that really it is a
whodunit but it's not really who does
yeah someone had commented on twitter is
like Oh what if heart and coal or you
know actually the same person it's like
no I don't want to sit that's lame I
don't want to see that I don't want you
know I don't want he like hey at the
very air this show just doesn't seem
like it's gonna go in that direction I
hope it doesn't know I hope it doesn't
either and I'm glad that we got to see
you know rust and heart back together
again it's funny because both their
lives are really really sad at this
moment when t12 they just they don't
have any neither one of them has
anything going i love that conversation
they had is like rusty would ask you no
heart is like so how's life like you
know you gotta grow you know he's like
there's like he's like way don't think
you've ever asked me how my life yes you
know it's just they don't have anything
like they're just like yeah they showed
mcconaughey at home heat is a little
like hungry man dinner drinking a beer
and watching TV it's just kind of
they're both just lived really depressed
he hasn't seen his kids for a while you
know when he was when he visits his
ex-wife who's living large by the way
lamar that was great seeing machine
monaghan visit Russ at his bar and he's
like a good deal addict oh yeah he's
bitter he's still bitter he's like your
classes up the place get out of here
that was nice little scene I hope that
if they both survived the finale that
you'll find some measure of peace I
don't know I don't think it's gonna
happen that doesn't mean I don't think
that you go is that well there's only
one episode left and there's still a lot
of questions to be answered and I don't
think the show is gonna tie those
everything that you want which is fine
cuz I think it and I don't think it's
gonna tie the characters up right either
I don't you know one may die too may die
maybe one may be shocked to see whatever
they find they just destroy the mentally
and who knows it yeah I don't think it's
gonna end well for anybody no no these
guys have not been doing well over the
last well I guess they broke up in what
02 mm-hmm so yeah last 10 years I've
been struggling also if you know
McConaughey's character rust he
basically said after we do this I want
to kill myself that's basically what he
said yeah he's like we have a witty kept
sin you have a debt or uh something he
was kept saying the word you have you
have an obligation like you have to do
this like you need to do this with me
like this so then he says after he's
done I'm gonna tie it off why speaking
about his own life and even even even
heart you know Woody Harrelson's
character when he's talking to Monaghan
you know she says you know the way
you're talking to me you're actually
like you're saying goodbye like I'm not
gonna see you again and he doesn't say
anything but I mean I think he knows
this could be it I mean they're going
into the Lions Den I mean this who knows
what they're gonna see you know well I
think for him though it's like oh I made
this is a dangerous situation I may die
or go to prison or something like that
with with rust he's saying after we
solved this case cuz I think he's
confident they're gonna solve it
everything that he's just gonna offer
him so yeah life's over i'm done cuz
that's like the only thing basically in
his life remaining it's all that's left
is just to kill himself poor guy this
shows been it's been great it's been a
fun ride it's been one of the more
interesting television series I've seen
in a while we'll see how it all ends i'm
not going to go so far as I was like the
best
in a long time this is a very good
anthology this is much stronger than a
American Horror Story just let's talk
anthologies I'm saying this is much
stronger guess compared to like breaking
backs it's like that's like a whole five
season 18 episode run so I get some more
of a miniseries or anthology this is
much stronger than American Horror Story
I think from the oh yeah much stronger I
mean the season finale has to like
totally like just tank tank or just
totally suck for me to be like I'll
screw this show HBO is not shown to
anybody no critics haven't even seen it
yet so my expectations may be too high
for this finale I know I that's what I'm
trying to have to try to temper the
locks I don't be like this is gonna be
the brightest thing ever like I need a
big okay this is the show it's gonna end
and I'm going to take it like it's gonna
be tough it's hard i mean we're getting
excited we still des I so geeked out
watch a lot of TV see a lot of movies
but we still geek out about this alright
so that's what we thought of the episode
what do you think what do you think is
gonna happen the final episode you can
post your comments below on the website
thing CARICOM or on our youtube channel
think hero pro make sure to subscribe to
that yeah we're gonna check us out on
twitter come child genocide let us know
what you think of the show are you still
with it or are you loving it more from
the beginning loving it more now are you
still loving it the same as you always
have we can find us at think hero i'm at
griffin de and we also have a Facebook
page that's facebook.com slash think
Carol fans and make sure you like that
page and share our videos on Twitter and
other social networking
you